welcome back to las vegas now so if the
kids got a new bike or scooter or
skateboard for the holidays they
definitely need a helmet to go with it
and they can get one for free this
weekend at jaguar land rover right here
in vegas here to tell us more about the
event is brian zink a police officer for
the clark county school district and i
think we have someone else around pro
bmx writer ricardo laguna is in the
house how are you guys thanks for having
us thank you guys for being here ricardo
i think you need a helmet when you're
riding your bike and you know
i have it on this place so i have to
make sure it looks really good yeah
absolutely this is the 13th year you
guys are doing this let's first talk
about just the importance of the helmets
and why this event is so important for
the community yeah so as we know lots
and lots of kids and adults get bikes
and scooters for christmas so
it's scientifically proven that wearing
a helmet like this will greatly reduce
any risk of getting a serious head
injury or neck injury if you get into an
accident can also protect your face if
you uh you know hit the curb something
like that so you know come out this
saturday the land rover sorry jaguar
land rover las vegas get a free helmet
ricardo's going to be there with his
friends doing this crazy bmx show it's
amazing the feats that these guys do is
just incredible so you know come out
they're all free and we're going to give
them away until we until we run out
that's awesome and so important and
ricardo helmets are important for all
ages right kids to adults exactly i
always tell people like look i'm in
dinosaur my sport but one of the reasons
why that's uh
possible is because i wear my safety
equipment and i know there's been a lot
of parents that they either a forgot to
buy the helmet or b they couldn't
purchase a helmet so we tried to fulfill
that gap and at the meantime there was
one guy that met me 13 years ago he met
me at this event got a helmet and now i
hire him to do shows with me so it's
pretty wild that his career kind of
started at this event how cool is that
and that just shows you that one helmet
can lead to a lot more adventures and
special things down the road and ricardo
let's just talk about i've seen you i
mean we got a little taste of it but
what will you be doing out there to make
it a fun event yeah yeah so we're going
to set up a miniature skate park and i'm
going to bring the local best hometown
heroes we're going to be performing some
of the wildest like basically what you
see at dx games so you guys can see it
up and close and personal meet and
greets it's kind of a bummer a little
bit of a hiccup we're gonna have the del
sol mariachi group but now that's a
little bit of a curveball but we're
gonna have plenty of different
activities where we're going to have
basically the clark county school police
department they have a lot of like at
the petting zoo you get to meet them i
even saw some kids sitting on the
motorcycle so that opportunity might be
there yeah we just saw some video from
previous years it looks like such a fun
time but also important to raise
awareness and for people who want to
come as the event free or how does it
work it's absolutely free so it's going
to start at 11 and we'll go until one
o'clock or until we run out of helmets
and like ricardo said i believe officer
cook and oreo will be there everyone
loves them we'll have some of our
motorcycles and our squad cars out there
too so kids can come out interact with
law enforcement interact with ricardo
and get a free helmet well thank you
guys so much we're really excited for
this event be sure to get out there and
get your free helmets and before we end
ricardo yeah do a little something to
wrap this up here putting you on the
spot super cool
here we go and then go oh yeah
thank you guys so much all right